[Musique]
c'est un mâle ou une femelle enceinte
faut regarder crise alors absolument pas
[Musique]
en vigueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
danseurs venus j'étais attendu à l'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais c'était les poussant dans les
chaussettes
ça déboule à l'élu
[Musique]
ces conseils sont plus calmes et oui je
maintiens plus à quoi il parle ce soir
apple zsa zsa zsa zsa zsa zsa laudrup je
savais
[Applaudissements]
mais sans gluten sans gluten j'étais
même pas d'une telle a vu express du
championnat aussi un joli dans la boue
il est allé trop belles dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
on va faire ça à 8h à la tirage au sort
des poules
c'est dans les 30 boussois question dans
les trois doivent rester debout
ça n'est pas le 39e ça n'est pas le 31
vous n'êtes pas mieux
et vous 24 c'est non
c'est le sang froid
bravo monsieur en trois ok c'est notre
dépôt
[Musique]